Uh,
hey everyone.
Welcome to Tosca.
Google.
My name is Dana Hind Klein.
And today it is my pleasure to introduce Jack Horner,
paleontologist and professor at Montana State University.
Uh,
he is a consultant on the Jurassic Park Franchise and was a consultant on this
latest one drastic world.
Welcome.
Thank you.
[inaudible]
so you've been with the series from the beginning.
In fact,
part of your works inspired the series,
correct?
That's what they say.
Um,
so what's it been like to be sort of evolved from this role of being an
inspiration for it?
You know,
they say that part of the character of Alan Grant is based on your work,
um,
to becoming this sort of influencing factor on the science behind it.
Yeah.
Okay.
I don't know what to say about it.
Yeah,
I'm glad my character hasn't been eaten.
Survival is good.
Survival.
It's definitely good.
Um,
well let you know it's been the,
the novel came out in 1990 and the first film came out in 1993 and we've seen a
lot of developments in the field of paleontology since then.
You know,
we've,
we've learned a lot about dinosaurs since then.
Um,
what are some of the things,
you know,
there's,
with a respect for the fact that it is science fiction,
what are some of the things that you do,
wish they'd been able to incorporate that we've discovered since then?
Um,
I actually,
nothing really,
I mean,
when,
when I was,
when I was working on Jurassic Park one,
Steven and I had a lot of arguments about whether the velociraptors should have
feathers on be colorful,
and he won all of those arguments.
He said a technicolor feathered dinosaurs not going to scare anyone.
It's a fair concession.
So they're gray and,
you know,
featherless Gary,
I guess.
Um,
well,
were there times that you were able to say like,
all right,
that's not gonna be scary,
but let me tell you about this and this is going to terrify people.
Um,
no.
No.
Okay.
All right then.
Um,
so obviously you're a wealth of information for the filmmakers to come to.
what were,
what were some of the questions that they asked you that you were able to advise
them on?
Well,
there's a lot of,
well,
first off,
my job really was to make sure that the dinosaurs looked as good as they could
without feathers and you know,
color,
um,
but looked as accurate as they could based on the science of the time.
Now remember that was 1992 and then I think we did a pretty good job of that.
But then,
you know,
Steven took him and made him act actors out of them and they,
everything they do is fictional.
I mean,
they run too fast or in many cases,
you know,
a little bigger than they should be,
which is not a bad thing because we actually know that dinosaurs grew through
most of their lives.
And so people are always going to find bigger,
bigger t rexes and you know,
bigger everything.
So that's not a big deal.
But,
but my job was to make sure that the dinosaurs looked good and then,
and then
mostly just,
you know,
make sure that there were,
that things were accurate,
as accurate as they could be.
So that basically what he said is you didn't want third graders to send him
nasty letters.
And so,
so there was a,
there was a time when we were doing the kitchen scene and there was some raptors
that came in the kitchen and then you,
you,
you all know that.
And originally they were going to come in and flick their fork tongue around and
I said,
you know,
you,
you cannot do that because they didn't have four times.
We know that for sure,
because if they did,
they had,
would have had Jacobson's organ and they don't have that.
So we know that for sure.
And so he said,
all right,
but we need that.
We need something for that space.
We need,
you know,
we've got that time limit,
that time in the,
in the movie.
And so we have to have something.
So we,
uh,
that's when we changed the,
the scene to them.
It's coming to the door and snorting and fogging up the window.
And that took them the basically,
you know,
that,
that's the one thing that really sort of moved them away from being very
reptilian lucking to being warm blooded.
It's the only warm blooded animals can do that.
So that was,
that was one thing I got in there that I was very happy about because he kept,
he told me when we first started,
he didn't want monsters,
but I had to keep moving him away from monsters because that's,
he has really what he wanted
monsters.
But that's it.
Yeah.
Um,
so I mean that's a great example,
but what are some of the other sort of characteristics that we've,
we can discover based on dinosaurs,
sort of the,
the discovery of their remains?
Um,
you know,
we can tell just on a basic level that like,
oh,
uh,
herbivores and carnivores have different teeth.
How do we kind of extrapolate their behavior patterns based on that?
And what,
what were you able to sort of,
well,
you know,
the first off the Alan Grant character,
the reason that's
the sort of the park that is based on me is his,
you know,
he's in his,
in the book and in the,
in the movie he's,
he's this guy who studies dinosaur behavior in Montana.
And then,
so that's what,
you know,
Michael Crighton took from my books and,
and the behavior that we do,
we actually were able to determine that dinosaurs cared for their young,
brought food to the babies.
You know,
and we did it all from looking at the geological evidence.
I mean,
we found baby dinosaur skeletons in nus like structures,
and it was the first time that had ever been seen.
So,
so you can do behavioral science on dinosaurs,
even though they're all dead and the latest stuff we've been working on,
and we,
you can see it in the new movie,
but it's very subtle.
Um,
a baby try Sarah to,
there's some baby triceratops in the new,
in the new movie and,
and kids are riding him,
but you'll notice the horns actually curve backward,
the horns of the baby's curve backward.
And,
um,
and then so what we know is that baby dinosaurs,
actually baby triceratops actually look different than adult triceratops.
Uh,
babies grew and as they grew their horns,
curt actually arc backwards.
And then when they read this start to reach sexual maturity actually grew
forward.
And when they're sexually mature,
their horns are straightforward.
And so,
uh,
and that's how,
that's one of the ways we know that they're very social animals because we see
the same thing in mammal in mammals and birds.
We see it in us,
right?
We can always tell a juvenile from an adult and we know that when they lose
those juvenile characteristics right out the door,
they go and they have to get a job.
So,
so,
you know,
um,
skeletal maturity,
sexual maturity,
these are all things that we can actually tell in the fossil record.
So we get a few of those things we could stick in the movie
that's going to say,
I think a,
is it a Paki Sefo source appears in one of the films and it's another one of the
creatures that the dome headed shifting kind of.
They talk about them crashing your heads together and we've actually proved that
they could only do that once,
lay on there.
Just remember they,
that was their first time.
Um,
but it's great that sort of,
there's this,
this element in that they do want to respect the kind of as much of the
scientific integrity that they can.
Um,
so you mentioned the nesting sort of habits and like maternal paternal instinct.
That's definitely also something that appears with the t rexes and the previous
films.
Um,
were you,
were you ever upset that the Maiasaura didn't get to appear?
It was in the book.
That's all right.
Um,
so can you,
can you,
can you talk about some of the other sort of contributions where you kind of got
to say,
like you mentioned the raptor as you mentioned,
the triceratops.
What are some of the other ones where you just said like,
he,
you have to,
well,
let's respect the,
oh,
there's not,
there's not a lot of them because,
you know,
as we all know,
there's not a lot of science actually shown.
I mean,
the dinosaurs basically are chasing somebody.
the plant theaters are eating plants or,
or standing around waiting to get eaten by something.
I,
since they are getting eaten.
Yes,
true.
I was just dirt,
you know,
we just don't see it.
A lot of the behavioral stuff up.
Um,
there was one interesting thing in the first movie.
I think it was the first one.
I might've been the second one.
Anyway.
Um,
we have a dinosaur pie,
right?
I'll dinosaur he both done and,
and it looked like elephant dung and I said,
you know,
we can't look like Elephant Dung.
It's gotta look like bird poop.
Right?
So it can't be just a bunch of ball and looking at things that actually has to
be a big white thing.
We went round and round about that.
I don't know if it's necessarily always want to pick.
Um,
well,
you know,
that dinosaurs that,
as long as you don't have to handle it,
it defies the dumb law.
Hello?
The one that's in the movie,
you know,
a pile of Dung should never be any higher than the place it came from.
Good to remember.
Um,
sort of speaking of the actual remains and not,
not that type of her remains,
but,
um,
they're,
you know,
there's not a ton of science mentioned the movie,
but the originals,
you know,
we,
he extracted the DNA from a mosquito,
but we know that like if the biomaterial when actually hold up,
but you guys have actually been able to extract material from fossils.
Um,
could you talk a little bit maybe about be rex
be rex is,
well,
it used to be a very special dinosaur until just very recently.
Um,
it was a dinosaur.
It's a tyrannosaurus rex and it was found under a thousand cubic yards of rock
and it produced soft tissues,
clear,
flexible blood vessels that we were able to etch out of the internal structure
and internal parts of the bone.
And we also were able to get Collagen,
the protein Collagen.
And we were able to get cells with Nuclei and unfortunately,
no DNA,
the DNA had broken down.
But what we've learned since then is that,
that these soft tissues we'll preserve and there they're fixing agent is iron.
Uh,
but what's interesting is,
you know,
when we think about a fossil dinosaur,
any animal that dies and when it dies,
it begins to rot and it rots because bacteria gets in there and start speeding
on it.
But if bacteria can't get into it and you're fixing agent is quick enough,
which is iron,
of course,
iron is heme is the,
is the basis of hemoglobin and it's already in the vessels.
And so you're fixing agent is already there.
And what we've discovered is that these tissues,
as long as they don't get broken down by bacteria right away,
we'll actually last forever clear and flexible,
which is pretty cool.
And it's changed our whole notion of what fossilization is because be fossilized
and still be flexible.
And yeah,
it just chemistry.
That's what you have to remember.
You have to adjust to camera.
Strangely,
the easy Kevin.
No,
no,
but it's great.
I mean,
I suppose theoretically if you'd written the book today,
you know,
he could,
instead of a mosquito would be a femur bone,
which I know Dna,
but no DNA.
Um,
but it does bring us to kind of another thing that you're working on that kind
of is taking the fiction part of out of science fiction.
Um,
and that's the chicken a source and drilling a dinosaur.
you know,
it's,
it's definitely something that I could see the fictional John Hammond dreaming
up.
But would you mind telling us about how to build the dinosaur?
Right.
So the,
the premise behind all of this was,
you know,
Jurassic Park was try to bring dinosaurs back in and we know we can't do that
week.
I have tried many times to extract DNA from a dinosaur and we've always failed.
And it's probably,
we think because the DNA molecule is huge and it just is not very stable,
it breaks down very quickly.
And so it just comes apart too easily.
And even the mammoth elephant that's 10,000 years old,
they have fragments of DNA,
but they're tiny.
They're just only a few hundred base pair.
And that's the only 10,000 years.
And so,
you know,
even if we got DNS,
even if we found some fragments that were still together from a dinosaur,
they'd still probably only be in the tens of base pair.
So we're know we're never going to make a dinosaur that way.
So,
you know,
birds are living dinosaurs,
they are dinosaurs.
And so,
and so they carry dinosaur DNA obviously since they are dinosaurs.
And,
but when you look at a bird and you look at a dinosaur,
if you look at specialty at their skeletons,
you know,
the,
uh,
the skeleton of a bird chicken,
um,
has no tail.
It has wings.
It has no teeth.
It's got this beak and you know,
looks like ticking.
But edit is a dinosaur,
you know,
and I keep trying to tell the sixth graders it's an Isr and they just say it's
not cool enough looking.
So,
so to make it cool bird into a diner,
you know,
make a cool dinosaur.
Um,
what we're doing now is looking for atavistic genes and other words,
ancestral genes that the birds might still be carrying that are just turned off
right there.
So to lose the tail,
in other words,
when we went from archaeopteryx like animals with long tails to any bird we have
now that has a short tail,
there is a genetic pathway that's missing,
right?
And so we're looking for those historical genetic pathways to reinstate them.
And so we're going in and actually going into an embryo and determining when
particular genes are turned on,
at what stage of their development they're turned on and when they're turned
off.
And,
and trying to adjust those so that we can actually get a bird to hatch out with
a long tail.
Um,
so teeth,
so we,
we have these four,
four things.
There's teeth,
the beak,
the snout making it,
changing it,
the tail and the arms and hands and teeth were accomplished.
Back in the 90s,
there was a group at the University of Wisconsin that actually was able to turn
a gene on and without adding anything to a burn,
get chickens to have teeth.
Now they're first generation teeth.
They couldn't actually grow through the Keratin of the beat.
So they're just,
they're implanted in the jaw.
But you know,
we have them.
So we know that all we have to do is knock out the,
uh,
the,
Keratin to get it to come through.
Just a few weeks ago,
a group at Harvard and Yale were able to transform the beak into a mouth that
looks like a dinosaur.
And that,
you know,
that actually is proof of concept.
That was a atavistic gene that they actually turned on and change the form of
its mouth.
We are working on the tail,
which is the hardest part because we actually,
in order to,
in order to get a tail to grow,
we actually aren't going to have to add vertebrae.
We can,
we,
we have,
we have gone in and found the atavistic gene.
We can get it to produce about 14 vertebrae,
um,
which is sort of an ancestral state,
but is basically what a bird already has,
except they fused the end of it together to make what they call,
what we call a [inaudible] style.
We can,
we can sort of sort those out right now,
but it's still not a long tail.
So what we're,
we're working on now is actually trying to figure out how to put basically an
alligator like tail on a bird and,
and we're making good progress.
We've,
we've actually done it a couple of times,
but we can't really,
we had some problems.
We can't,
we,
we can't tell whether we've added tail or change the position of the pelvis.
So in the embryo,
you know,
everything's done at very small states and so it's just hard to tell where we
are right now.
But then the hand actually going back to,
uh,
a hand transforming it back from a wing,
we don't think I'll be too much difficulty because it really is just a matter
of,
it's,
it's a gene that fuses the three digits together and we just have to infuse
them.
And we think that'll be a relatively easy process.
But the tail is the big,
the big thing.
Because as soon as we can add vertebrae,
I mean,
it has just tremendous application to the medical field.
And I mean,
there's just so many things that we'll be able to do,
but it is the most complex.
But right now,
figure teeth and the mouth,
that's 50%.
We're halfway there,
hopefully halfway,
not to the rafters running around,
but,
and you,
but we make them one at a time.
I think they'd have a hard time out in the wild,
trying to find another chicken,
a source to meet with.
And if they did make good,
just going to have chickens and they're only gonna like chicken food.
Jamie.
Um,
but you,
you do sort of mentioned in your book,
you know,
it's not going to be drastic partner in this as much as some of us might want
our own pet raptor.
Um,
but it's version one,
right?
Right.
It's the first version.
So
what did we make up Donald Chicken?
I mean,
that is the first version.
And then we,
you know,
by then we will know,
I know enough about different genes that
we might be able to,
you know,
version two could look an awful lot,
an awful lot closer to a velociraptor.
Here we go.
Um,
but it,
but it was an interesting thing.
Um,
you know,
it's still,
it's never going to be,
we're never going to have a velociraptor whenever we're going to have a version
of the ancestral,
you know,
qualities of it.
But that's something I think they,
after you of the characters actually expressing Jurassic parks,
they go,
no,
these aren't dinosaurs.
These are whatever things you've mixed with them to bring dinosaurs to life.
So it's a,
it's why we have in dominance rex,
the
super amazing Badass and Tom Finisterre definitely,
which we want,
which to me
it's actually the most plausible thing that we've made in Jurassic Park so far.
I think about that.
It is,
we know that we can't get dinosaurs back from DNA,
right?
But we can make a hybrid.
I mean,
we make transgenic animals right now.
Um,
we definitely change,
you know,
we,
we genetically engineer all sorts of things.
I mean if you all these funny little dog Chihuahuas,
you know,
I mean they are genetically modified wolves.
That's what they are.
And so breeding is one of the biological modification tools that we use to
change how an animal looks already.
And then transgenic engineering,
which an example is making glow fish.
So we take genes out of,
uh,
a jellyfish and stick them in a zebra fish and make them glow.
And now we know that we can do that with anything.
I mean,
you can,
yeah,
you could do it with a human if you want it to do you mean seriously?
You just stick it in the embryo.
And so we've got glowing,
we've got glow in the dark cats,
rabbits,
you name it.
You can make anything glow in the dark by doing transgenic engineering.
And that's the whole idea of in dominance Rex's is to make it,
it's just basically genetic transgenic hybrid,
which we already know how to do.
So if we could get dinosaurs back,
we could make a dominance rex,
I think I would have a lot more consequences then you want to happen.
But,
um,
no,
it's,
I don't spoil it for people haven't seen it yet.
Um,
you know,
it's,
it is sort of this thing,
you know,
they say in the book,
the mix it with tree frogs.
You're,
uh,
the DNA with tree frogs.
You know,
we're talking about engineering a chicken dinosaur,
like non Avian.
Um,
so what's,
where do you see the future of the field going?
Okay.
Like feature of a Paleontology Ology?
Only because,
you know,
it's,
it's evolved in the sense that like,
it used to be,
oh preserve,
you know,
we want things for museums now it's like,
let's cut it open and let's see what's inside.
That's right.
That's what we do.
Yes.
Um,
so we will continue to cut things open and learn all sorts of new things as far
as,
you know,
our genetic engineering efforts.
You know,
I as wacky and wild as it sounds.
I mean,
we could start making some,
no,
I keep,
you know,
I throw this out.
So since we can make glow in the dark animals,
we could actually make it glow in the dark unicorn.
Okay.
Why not?
Right.
Fine.
The Unicorn,
it actual idea Unicorn would actually be easier than the dyno check in.
I mean,
it's just a horse with a thing on his head right then and it turns out there's
actually,
they're actually
mmm
ossicones on or even drafts if you ever look at a draft really.
Plus it actually has a horn in the mill.
It's a horny structure and,
and modifiable.
So I actually think we could make a unicorn pretty easily.
Yeah.
Make a lot of navy wanted art
as if one feature wasn't good enough.
Let's make it glow in the dark.
So the chicken to stores,
like you mentioned before,
it's not just about the discovery in especially like the tail thing.
It involves a lot of,
the spine involves a lot of,
um,
sort of discovering at what points in development do these things happen.
Um,
could you talk a little bit about the Applique,
more about the applications to as bipeds.
I don't know.
Everyone's worried about the applicant.
You know,
why going,
why make it dynamite chicken?
Well,
you know,
I don't think I have to say that to anybody in here.
Actually.
I think all of you know why we want a dial chicken,
right?
Because this is going to be fun.
I mean that's just so,
it's all there is to it and all the kids are going to like it.
But there's a lot of,
you know,
people who are grownups that always say what good is it?
What would you do it for?
Well,
you know,
as I was saying,
learning how learning what different genes do and how to turn them on and how to
turn them off as huge application in the medical field.
And so,
you know,
and quite frankly,
genetics is extremely boring and nobody wants,
you know,
nobody ever goes to college studied genetics that I can,
I can imagine.
I mean it's just awful.
So,
so at least if you thought you could make a dyno check in,
you know,
had to be,
it sounds like it'd be pretty interesting.
So you know,
and if you can think and start thinking about making new kinds of animals be,
rather than,
you know,
bigger tomatoes,
it's at least a good way to get kids interested in a pretty boring science.
I'm not going to go so far as call it boring.
I do think it gives,
you know,
it's an interesting tangible,
visible presentation of these are some applications of it.
Think of what you could think of.
You can have your uncle and the dark unicorn that's right on the dark Donald
chicken.
Even better.
Do we have any questions?
I'm going to come into the mic.
Hello.
I'm Alex.
I'm kind,
kinda curious to know your thoughts on the usage of this genetic research in
animal conservation.
Considering the northern black rhino just last week when extinct,
um,
do,
has there been any kind of like conference between your research groups and
other research groups in the animal conservation to,
to use this,
uh,
developing technology to preserve these jeans and,
a very,
uh,
precise manner so that maybe in the future with technology technological
increased,
we can bring these animals that we had alive back from extinction
and kill de extinction is a wholly different thing.
Um,
de Extinction,
the Da,
then there are a lot of de extinction projects going on right now.
They're trying to get the passenger pigeon back it,
trying to get the,
um,
the,
uh,
Tasmanian Wolf back.
Um,
we're trying to get the mammoth elephant back,
all of which were probably wiped out by humans.
The Dodo bird who know,
I don't know if we need a Dodo but,
but,
but uh,
de extinction in order to get them back does require DNA and it requires enough
to put it to inject in the cell and,
and make an animal such as,
uh,
as,
as a mammoth elephant,
which is pretty plausible and it's pretty plausible because we have elephants.
So,
so chances are pretty good if we have a
chunk of DNA,
at least a pretty good chunk of one,
and then we add it to elephant DNA,
we're going to get some kind of a hairy elephant of,
I'm sorry,
with the Rhino,
actually we have their complete DNA and we have it preserved.
So as soon as we figure out how to clone DNA,
we can do that.
But right now what we would end up doing is taking that complete strand of DNA
and sticking it in one of the non extinct rhinos.
And it still would be some kind of combination.
And that's the problem.
We don't,
we,
we rely right now on,
on a cloning technology that involves a particular kind of cell from a
particular kind of animal.
And we don't know how to take an individual strand of DNA and make it make
something.
We don't know how to do that yet,
but one weekend and then we can,
we could probably bring back a number of things that are going extinct,
but it breaks down too quick.
So going back and sort of bringing things back from very deep time is going to
be impossible and I mean impossible.
Not maybe someday it's just because you're never going to get us complete strand
of DNA from anything much older than even probably a few hundred years.
Hi,
thanks for coming in.
Um,
I just wanted to add a comment first about,
um,
glowing unicorns going in the dark unicorns.
We have the same kind of problem in computer science where it can seem really
dull to get people interested in it,
especially in ads.
So we have,
um,
so we have machine learning to kind of,
you know,
excite people,
artificial intelligence,
the thought of potentially,
you know,
robots in the future.
So that's our glowing unicorn equivalent in our field.
Um,
I was wondering,
so when I was growing up,
um,
the,
the science at the time was saying that there was a big extinction event
involving dinosaurs,
but I've heard more recently that maybe it wasn't extinction at all.
Maybe it was just evolution.
Um,
what's the,
like what's the,
what's the consensus now?
Okay.
Extinction event.
I downplay it myself
at the end of most museum exhibits.
There's,
you know,
a big thing about the media are coming down in Gel and everything off.
And I just have a burden because of it.
You know,
I,
I just basically don't think about extinction because,
you know,
we,
we're,
we classify animals,
right?
So we put them in the categories and then we say,
Oh,
look at that category goes extinct.
And you know,
it's just,
birds are just fine and birds are dinosaurs.
So it seems kind of weird.
But,
but uh,
but no,
the all,
so we separate them now into non avian dinosaurs and avian dinosaurs.
So all birds are avian dinosaurs and all the ones that went extinct or non avian
dinosaurs and non avian dinosaurs didn't go extinct by some catastrophic event
probably,
although
it might be some heightened out in Africa.
Um,
with this kind of research,
always have people who have ethical quandaries regarding this kind of,
um,
development over time.
What would you say to people who have these kind of ethical quandaries about how
this could be applied medically or two people or bad science kind of thing?
Yeah,
yeah.
I,
I was just in London a few days ago and there was someone who stood up and was
very adamant about talking about where you draw a line.
And I was thinking,
you know,
that that's a,
it's an odd question and that's an odd question to a scientist because we have
no way of figuring out where I draw a line.
I mean,
it's lines are personal preference.
I,
I think science,
I think scientists need to discover everything that's possible to discover.
Now,
a lot of it might have bad consequences,
but if,
if we draw a line and say,
okay,
we're not going to study this particular thing,
but somebody in some other country,
it doesn't have that same line and they make something that's dangerous to us,
but we've never figured out a way to deal with it or done.
So you know,
we need,
I think we need to learn how to do everything.
And then when it comes to these animals,
I mean again,
nobody drew a line and said,
whoa,
we shouldn't make it Chihuahua.
But you know,
somebody could have,
I mean it's just,
I,
I just don't think there's,
I don't think there's any particular reason to draw any kind of align that.
But that's my personal preference.
Also.
It doesn't,
a lot of it gets sort of sensationalized.
Like we,
we test on mice,
we test,
we test it on fruit flies,
fruit flies and Mites nurse that same thing.
But we are doing sort of experimentation on all of ways.
It's beer ranting on animals and plants.
I mean everything or
drawing aligners.
It's just a,
it's an interesting concept.
So you mentioned that a,
if you took two dyno checkins and made them,
you would get a chicken.
So I'm guessing that you are altering just the expression of genes by chemicals
in the MRI.
I'm not their DNA.
That's not their DNA.
Have you considered,
okay,
what we're going to take the DNA that we know in an alligator makes the tail
splice it in and then hey,
we'd actually have to die no chickens that would make dyno check ins or whatever
else.
Yeah,
yeah.
No,
I,
um,
I would,
once we sort of have some idea how to make a dental checkup,
um,
I,
it's kind of a pain in the butt,
the,
you know,
to make one at a time.
So if we could change their DNA,
that'd be good.
So we're good.
Make them go.
So they make themselves,
so I guess as a consultant on the Jurassic Park films,
you have a lot of insight into how the movie portrays dinosaurs.
Uh,
do you think in general,
movies have been good for the paleontology industry and getting people excited
about it?
Or do you think it's had a lot of negative consequences by the way that it
portrays and maybe wrongly?
Yeah,
I don't think it has any negative at all.
I mean,
when I,
in 1993 when Jurassic Park came out and before Jurassic Park one came out,
I had,
I dunno,
three graduate students,
guys,
three graduate student guys.
When Jurassic Park came out just after it.
Yeah.
Came out,
I had an,
I had,
I had incredible numbers of people trying to get into the program.
I ended up with 18 almost instantly and it was 50,
50 women and guys,
so I know what that,
what that movie did and it,
you know,
no one was talking about,
the dinosaurs not having feathers.
We have time for one more question.
Do you have any sense of how small the population of dinosaurs survive the
potential extinction event that led to modern birds?
Okay.
Actually the animals that led to modern birds,
we're doing very well.
Early on it wasn't the extinct one.
It wasn't a group of extinct dinosaurs.
That's not the right way to put it in.
Uh,
birds evolved back in the,
in the Jurassic period long before the,
and so they were actually doing pretty well and a lot of,
obviously a lot of birds went extinct as well.
Um,
but,
um,
obviously the,
the ones that made it through the,
the little what they were all little birds,
probably Robin's lies,
things that we have very little fossil record of,
um,
are the ones that gave rise to basically all of the burdens that we have now.
Great.
But they had,
they were very far along.
One of the things that's really hard to imagine is just the amount of time
that's involved,
you know,
from the late Jurassic to the extinction period of time is,
is more time than has existed since the extinction of dinosaurs and til now.
So,
I mean,
we just have these,
you know,
huge spans of time to evolve all sorts of things.
I have a new dinosaur I'm trying to name right now and that's,
that's something weird characteristics.
I think it's,
its head is full of these incredible,
um,
nerve bundles and there's no animal on this earth that looks anything like this.
I,
so,
I mean,
there's not even a good way to guess what this animal was doing unless I was
telepathic.
I mean,
it's just really odd characteristics.
And we see this in a lot of these dinosaurs.
I mean,
there's just,
they just had so long to evolve.
They've got these things that,
these characteristics that are so different than animals alive today.
That's why,
you know,
you could make all kinds of stuff for Jurassic Park.
I mean,
we could just come up with wild,
crazy ideas,
even for ones that probably did exist,
let alone the ones that we can.
Manufacturer
dinosaurs are cool.
Dancers are very cool.
Um,
thank you so much for joining us
and
thanks [inaudible].